so my journey began in the Bronx New
York in a one-bedroom apartment with my
two sisters and immigrant mother I loved
our neighborhood it was Lively
there was always merengue blasting
neighbors socializing on building Stoops
and animated conversations over Domino
playing it was home and it was sweet but
it wasn't simple in fact everyone has
schooled you the black where we lived
because it was where people came to buy
weed and other drugs and with drug
dealing comes conflict so often went to
sleep to the sound of gunshots I spent
much of my childhood worried worried
about our safety and so did our mother
she worried that the violence we witness
would overtake our lives that our
poverty meant that the neighbors with
whom we lived and shared space would
harm us our entire life was in the Bronx
my mother's anxiety spurred her into
action and soon we were driving so fast
to Connecticut to boarding school
campuses with full scholarships and tow
man don't underestimate the power of a
mother determined to keep her children
safe
at boarding school for the first time I
was able to sleep without worry I could
leave my dorm room a lot walk a barefoot
in the grass and look up to see a night
sky full of stars happy novelties but
there were other novelties as well very
quickly I felt like I didn't belong I
learned that I didn't speak the right
way and to demonstrate the proper ways
of speaking my teachers gave me frequent
lessons in public on the appropriate way
to enunciate certain words a teacher
once instructed me in the hallway ass
gang she said this loudly Dina it's not
acting like you're running around with
an axe
that's silly now at this point you could
imagine the Snickers of my classmates
but she continued think about breaking
the word into ass and king and then put
the two together to say it correctly
asking there was some other moments that
reminded me that I didn't belong once I
walked into a classmates dorm room and I
watched her watch her valuables around
me like why would she do that thought to
myself and then there was the time when
another classmate walked into my dorm
room and yelled you as I was applying
hair grease to my scalp there is
emotional damage done when young people
can be themselves when they are forced
to edit who they are in order to be
acceptable it's a kind of
violence ultimately I'm a quintessential
success story I attended boarding school
in college in New England studied abroad
in Chile and returned to the Bronx to be
a middle school teacher I received a
Truman Scholarship a Fulbright and a
Soros fellowship and Aika List more but
I will
I earned my doctorate at Columbia
University and then I landed a job at
Yale I am proud of everything that I've
been able to accomplish on my journey
thus far I have eternal impostor
syndrome either I've been invited
because I'm a token which really isn't
about me but rather about a box I want
you to check off or I am exceptional
which means I've had to leave the people
I love behind it's the price that I and
so many others pay for learning while
black
[Applause]
I police myself all the time are my
pants too tight should I wear my hair up
or in afro should I speak up for myself
or will the power of my words be reduced
to she's angry why did I have to leave
the Bronx to gain access to a better
education and why in the process of
getting that better education that I
have to endure the trauma of erasing
what made me me a black girl from the
Bronx raised by an aunt Egon mother so
when I think about our current education
reform initiatives I can't help asking
what are our students of color learning
about themselves three three decades of
research reveal that students of color
are suspended and expelled at a rate
three times greater than white students
and are punished in harsher ways for the
same infractions they also learned this
through the absence of their lives and
narratives in the curricula the
co-operative children's book center did
a review of nearly 4,000 books and found
that only three percent were about
African Americans and they further
learned this through the lack of
teachers that look like them
an analysis of data from the National
Center for Education Statistics found
that forty five percent of our nation's
pre-k to high school students were
people of color while only 17% of our
teachers are our youth of color pay a
profound price when their schooling
since then the message that they must be
controlled that they must leave their
identities at home in
order to be successful every child
deserves an education that guarantees
the safety to learn in the comfort of
one's own skin
[Applause]
it is possible to create emotionally and
physically safe classrooms where
students also thrive academically I know
because I did it in my classroom when I
returned to teaching the Bronx so what
did that look like I centered my
instruction on the lives histories and
identities of my students and I did all
of this because I wanted my students to
know that everyone around them was
supporting them to be their best self so
while I could not control the
instability of their homes the
uncertainty of their next meal or the
loud neighbors that kept them from sleep
I provided them with a loving classroom
that made them feel proud of who they
are that made them know that they
mattered you know every time I hear or
say the word asking I'm in high school
again I'm thinking about ass and King
and putting the two together so that I
speak in a way where someone in power
will want to listen there is a better
way one that doesn't force kids of color
into a double bind a way for them to
preserve their ties to their families
homes and communities a way that teaches
them to trust their instincts and to
have faith in their own creative genius
thank you
[Applause]
you